hey
all right we're here at uh the more
rally and we finally got her i got
ashton winnie here with me um
so you are here and i i did see your
speech um
you were not probably the only one how
many other people do you think uh have
been really pushing the freedom of
speech stuff tonight
um you know i don't think enough to be
quite honest i think it's really
depressing that no one's talking about
internet censorship here and a lot of
times i do talk to people here
about internet censorship they don't
really seem to have a clue what's going
on it's like
alex joe's kind of kicked off every
single social media platform
and a lot of people do watch alex jones
and so it's really concerning a lot of
people don't realize that
the internet kind of is our way of
living
no it's not i'm doing an interview
yeah that's not for me thank you though
thank you for trying to deliver
mcdonald's while i was interviewing
somebody
thank you for trying to bring mcdonald's
in the middle of a [ __ ] interview
that's now my mcdonald's
did this [ __ ] order mcdonald's
did he pay for this i don't know
but did he pay for it i'm not paying
looking for you i've been looking for
you forever
[Music]
i i no i didn't but did i
am i paying for this how does this work
i'll take it see what's in there let's
let's
let's turn this into a date this is me
and ashton whittie on a date right now
we're having uh what do we have what do
we have in here oh
a happy meal and an apple pie
i cannot believe [ __ ] psychotic fans
would you like some fries would you like
some fries
probably yeah he was looking for me for
a while
are they good no no good do you want a
juice box
you want a juice box i feel like i feel
like ashton whitty drinking a juice box
would be [ __ ] good
good content i don't know what is going
yeah please
knock yourself out i don't dude that
[ __ ] me up so bad now i had all these
questions and [ __ ]
yeah now you have a happy meal and then
i was like rude to the guy i'm like why
the [ __ ] are you in here
[Laughter]
we need to continue well at least
at least we know we have internet clout
now we're getting
why the happy meal what a [ __ ] now
i'm all [ __ ]
let's go back to this now i got to go
back to my interview mcdonald's i'm
loving it
um so
you're uh you're a bit of an alex jones
uh fan an aficionado and a colleague
right i'm a little obsessed yes um so
what did you think about a little five
foot three ben shapiro running his
little dick sucker about our boy alex
ben shapiro needs to be put in the grave
oh
i love you now oh she's my favorite
that's all i needed to hear
um now everybody here is whining about
freedom of speech
however many many many of the people i
see here
were very very quick to counter signal
the alt-right about a year ago
and uh helped to get them thrown off of
social media platforms to save their own
skin
how has that worked out for them the
last another thing as i noticed is that
a lot of the people
who are seeing this happen especially
it's especially ben shapiro people are
letting it happen
i'm personally not a fan of daily
stormer yada yada yada red ice
but at the same time i think they should
have their their shows i think they
should have the
ability to see what they want to say
nick fuentes and i for example disagree
on many many things
but you know i'll still talk to nick
funtos and still have a conversation
with him
because if you can't have a conversation
with someone what's the point in free
speech
free speech allows us to have
conversations and debate each other to
make the world a better place
and so a lot of people yeah you know
daily storm may disagree with them
but wanting you know daily stormer off
the air but wanting your own podcast on
is very hypocritical again not a fan
daily storm whatsoever
but i'm pissed off alex jones is off the
air i'm obsessed with alex jones i think
alex jones the freaking american saint
listen i liked alex jones when you were
an embryo so i don't want to hear it
what i'm all i'm saying is is that i
think even antifa should have twitter
pages i think everyone should have a
twitter page i think everyone
had the right to see whatever nonsense
they want to say the fact is there's
only people on the right especially from
yadda yadda yadda you know who we're
talking about little mr five foot three
can't get on a roller coaster
people you're going down ben people like
him they only want their speech to go
out there they're just as bad as the
democrats they're just as bad as the
liberals and they're just as bad as the
same little [ __ ] hat and mongrels
i've asked your woody drinking a juice
box on our interview i can't get over
this
now i have a question for you it's kind
of a silly question if uh if
let's say like it's summerslam right we
gotta we got a u.s title match it's
gonna be kyle chapman
versus christopher cantwell who would
the fbi root for
god damn it that's a good answer i can't
even hate on that god damn it
um so you are saying though that you do
think that uh
obviously not agreeing with them but you
do think that the alt-right shouldn't be
uh
run off and unpersoned like george
orwell style no i don't think antifa
should be silenced i think everybody has
the right to say what the hell they want
to say
and all i'm asking is please don't hit
people's head with a bike lock like
antifa can say
the same communist [ __ ] they want
over and over again
and richard spencer can say the same
stupid democrat chill he does
disguise his alt-right stuff whatever
you can see what the hell you want to
say just please don't bash me in the
head with a brick
yeah and then if you do you're just
gonna get a misdemeanor and a one dollar
fine
is there anything you would like to tell
everybody here uh so we can get out of
the rain and start drinking again
i just want people to have like be
civilized human beings let people
say what they want to say if you don't
like something turn off the damn
computer and let me drink my juice box
she has a juice box all right we gave it
to her so we're friends now
um please uh because you know we're so
massive we have such a massive audience
you know so i want you to promote i'm
kidding dude promote your uh promote
yourself to our audience
all of which already know who you are
hey guys i'm ashton birdie your chances
are you probably already hate me
and uh because this guy can't stop
comparing me to a stripper but what's up
follow me on youtube i talk about basic
[ __ ] and uh why i hate ben shapiro
now
can we can we make up though i give you
juice box we're cool right we're gonna
get a little half hug here ash and
birdie join us
god damn it look i wanted it
[Laughter]
i can't not like you ever again so i'm
sorry i'm sorry for being mean
i'm going to eat it right now and say
tell me
i'm sorry for being mean no but i've
been unnecessarily mean to you
uh i think i think her and laura loomer
have gotten the real [ __ ] end of merch
so i need to be a little nicer and i'll
go back to picking on uh
i don't know who else is here joey
gibson's here still right we'll make fun
of joey gibson
if you weren't a shitty person though
you wouldn't be funny so
but i'm also a shitty person so uh yeah
thanks ashton birdie
uh enjoy the juice box it's been
wonderful talking to you
and uh thank you so much